alright now let's tackle Part B find the
average velocity of the particle for the
time period from zero is less than or
equal to T is less than or equal to 6 so
our average velocity that's just going
to be our change in position
which we could view as our displacement
divided by our change in time well what
is our change in position going to be
well they don't give us our position
function but they do give us our
velocity function and so to figure out
the average velocity we could figure out
our displacement which is going to be
equal to the integral of our velocity
the integral of V of T DT and we want to
find the average velocity for this time
period so we're going to go T equals
zero to T equals six and then we're
going to divide that by the amount of
time that goes by well our change in
time is going to be equal to 6 and so
this is going to be equal to the
integral from zero to 6 of 2 sine of e
to the T over 4 power plus 1 DT and then
all of that divided by 6 where did I get
this from well they tell us what our
velocity as a function of time is it's
that right over there
so we can get our calculator out to
solve this part so on our calculator we
would hit math and then we would want to
do number 9 which is definite integral
so I hit 9 and we are going to go from 0
to 6 of this is going to be 2 sine of e
to the so let me do second e to the and
I'll just use the variable X instead of
T because it's easier to type in X
divided by 4 power so that's my sign and
then let me close the parentheses for
the sine plus 1 and then I'm integrating
here with respect to X just because it
was more convenient and I am going to
get that and then I divide by 6 divided
by 6 and I get and when you're taking an
AP calculus exam it's important to round
to three decimal places unless they tell
you otherwise that's what they expect so
it's approximately equal to one point
nine four nine
approximately one point nine four nine
now let's do Part C so Part C find the
total distance traveled by the particle
from time T equals zero to T equals six
so you might say hey didn't we just
figure that out no this is displacement
and to remember the difference between
distance and displacement if I have
something that starts here it goes over
there and then it comes back to right
over there the distance traveled is the
total path length so it would be that
Plus this while the displacement would
just be this right over here so if you
want to figure out distance what you
want to do is take the integral of the
absolute value of velocity you could
think about it as you're taking the
integral of the speed function so this
is just going to be the integral from
zero to six of the absolute value of V
of T DT and then we can type this
actually let me just write it out since
you would want to do this if you're
actually taking the test
so it's integral from zero to six of the
absolute value of two sign of e to the T
over four plus one close the absolute
value DT which is going to be
approximately equal to so once again we
hit math definite integral we're going
from zero to six of now we'll hit math
again and then we'll go to number we see
absolute value the absolute value of 2
sine of e to the I'll use X again just
because it's easier to use on the
calculator and then I'll close the
parentheses on whoops let me make sure I
do this right so let me close the
parentheses on the sine and then I have
plus one and then there you go
and then I'm integrating with respect to
X
approximately twelve point five seven
three now let's do Part D I'll do it
right over here Part D for T between
zero and six the particle changes
Direction exactly once find the position
of the particle at that time so the way
and I'm going to tackle it is first I
need to think about at what time does
the particle change direction and then I
can figure out its position by taking
the integral of the velocity function so
how do I think about where that particle
changes direction well you're going to
change direction if your velocity is at
zero and right before that your velocity
was positive and then right after that
your velocity is negative or the other
way around right before that your faucet
was negative and then your velocity
after right after that is positive so we
just have to figure out when does V of T
equals zero so let's just say to sign of
e to the T over four plus one is equal
to zero and there's multiple ways you
can solve this but because we're allowed
to use a calculator we might as well do
that so we hit math and then we hit B
right over there I'll just hit enter
equation solver so I could just say look
the left side of my equation is 2 sine
of we are going to go e to the I'll just
use X as what I'm solving for because
it's easier to type in in the calculator
and close that parentheses plus one the
right-hand side is equal to zero and now
I just have to give an initial guess and
I'll just go right in between that
interval between T equals zero and T
equals six so I'll just put a three
right over there and now I just need to
solve it and I can do that by hitting
alpha and then solve and then you see it
got us to five point one nine six so T
is approximately equal to five point one
nine six but remember they're not asking
us for at what time does the particle
change direction they want to know
what's the position of the particle at
that time well we know how to find our
change in position our change in
position is going to be our displacement
from time equals zero to
I'm 5.19 six and the displacement we're
integrating the velocity function so
that's going to be 2 sine of e to the T
over 4 plus 1 DT now this is going to be
our change in position but where did we
start
well they say at x equals 0 or when X 1
at time 0 our position was 2 so this is
our change we would start here this
would give us our total position where
we started plus our change and so this
is going to be approximately equal to we
are going to have 2 plus and then I go
to math definite integral from 0 to 5
point one nine six and I've typed this
in many times already to sign of e of e
to the X divided by four power and then
close that parenthesis plus 1 and then
I'm integrating with respect to X and so
this gives us 14 point 1 3 5
approximately 14 point 1 3 5 is this
position and let me make sure that I put
those parentheses there in the right
place and we are done